so i have a question here from the cots
trickle and townsend chemistry and
chemical reactivity book
and i got their permission to do this
and it says a solution of potassium
permanganate has an absorb has an
absorbance
of 0.53 when measured
at 540 nanometers in a
1 centimeter cell what is the
concentration
what is the concentration of the
potassium permanganate
prior to determining the absorbance for
the unknown solution
the following calibration data were
collected for the spectrophotometer
so the way that we would tackle this is
we know that there is a linear
relationship
between absorbance and concentration we
could describe
it something like this that absorbance
is going to be equal to
some slope times our
concentration and you could say some
y-intercept if we're purist
about it then the y-intercept should be
zero because at a zero concentration you
should have a zero
absorbance but the way that chemists
would typically do it
is that they would put these points into
a
computer and then have the computer do a
linear regression you could also do that
by hand but that's a little bit out of
the scope
of this video and i did that i went to
desmos
and i typed in the numbers that they
gave
and this is what i got so i just typed
in these numbers
and then it fit a linear regression line
to it and it got these parameters
m is equal to this and b is equal to
this
now we could say significant figures it
seems like the small significant figures
here we have are three
but we could just view the m and the b
as intermediate numbers in our
calculations what i'm going to do is i'm
going to use this
m and b and then my final answer i'm
going to round to three significant
figures
so what this tells us is that our
absorbance is going to be
[Music]
5.65333
times our concentration minus
0.008
and now they've given us what a is let
me
get rid of all of this stuff here they
told us that our absorbance is
0.539 so we know that 0.539
is equal to 5.65333
c minus 0.0086
and then if you want to solve for c
let's see we could add this to both
sides first
so you get 0.539
plus 0.0086
is equal to 5.65333
c and then divide both sides by this and
you would get c
is equal to or is going to be
approximately equal to be a little
careful
all of these would really be approximate
c is going to be approximately equal to
0.539
plus zero point zero zero eight six
divided by five point
six five three three three and of course
we wanna round to
three significant figures all right
point five
nine plus .0086
is equal to that divided by 5.65333
is equal to this so if we go three
significant
figures this is going to be 0.0969
so i would write the concentration is
approximately 0.096
9 molar